alors en fait la halle alors suis
obligée bresse obligés de m'éloigner
samantha parce que en gros c'est
vraiment la situation en train de
devenir mais totalement a totalement
dégénéré
la baule et les membres des voltigeurs
en fait son arrivée il ya à peine cinq
minutes
hélas si vous voulez ça encore plus
embrasser en fait les petits groupes de
deux hommes dont on vous a parlé tout à
l'heure qui sont vêtus de noir et qui
sont en fait responsable de voilà deux
du fait que la situation dégénère mais
alors mais totalement entre ce qu'on a
vu qu'on est arrivé au début de l'année
de la manifestation aux alentours de
14h30 15h et ce qui se passe maintenant
c'est c'est absolument incroyable en
fait il n'ya pas du tout de moments
d'accalmie constamment en fait à peu
près toutes les deux trois minutes on
voit des affrontements entre donc
certains groupes de manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre qui en fait réplique
maintenant systématiquement reste plus
du trou stoïque et c'est vrai que on a
rencontré beaucoup de gens ici qui nous
ont dit qu'ils étaient très déçus tant
que la situation dégénère à ce point là
d'ailleurs je suis avec eux quelle heure
le duc les jaunes depuis la première
heure merci de répondre à nos questions
désolé je suis un peu essoufflée parce
qu on court beaucoup depuis tout à
l'heure vous êtes g légion depuis le
début vous vouliez rendre enfin montrer
votre soutien aux soignants aujourd'hui
est finalement voilà ce que ça donne
maintenant cette manifestation ça vous
inspire quoi bassam aspire je suis
vraiment désolé parce que il n'ya pas
longtemps à la police à venez applaudir
devant les hôpitaux et aujourd'hui on
avait un moment un très beau symbole on
a vu beaucoup de personnes soignants qui
ont avancé qui disait macron t'es foutu
l'hôpital et dans la rue ces personnes
là avance et on applaudit sans les mains
en l'air et ils ont été chargés aussi
aujourd'hui la fête pour les soignants
l'hommage pour les soignants a été
gâchée par les assauts policiers alors
oui il ya eu des altercations
mais c'est encore une fois dommage que
les policiers gâche les symboles qui a
représentent l'hôpital qui a sauvé nos
vies aujourd'hui est un point finalement
les gilets jaunes jeu
suit depuis le début du mouvement et je
me rappelle que en mai 2010 vous étiez
vous aviez déjà participé à une
manifestation en soutien aux hôpitaux
donc c'est quand même une thématique qui
vous tient à coeur depuis le départ mais
oui c'est une thématique qui nous tient
à coeur parce que depuis le départ on a
parlé un petit peu de la casse de nos
hôpitaux la casse de notre santé et la
cassa les gars ça allez allez faites par
le gouvernement
on lutte pour toutes ces cas sont lutte
pour toutes ces injustices et il ya un
moment on en a marre forcément on dit ah
le peuple est en colère c'est normal que
papier en colère on casse les hôpitaux
on casse nos services publics on enlève
nos zones aux lits dans les hôpitaux et
un moment c'est plus possible
alors finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que nous vous qu'est ce que vous allez
faire après cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui qui finalement ne se passe
pas comme c'était prévu mais qui est
quand même la première manifestation et
on va dire autorisée depuis la fin du
confinement est ce que qu'est ce qui va
se passer pour le mouvement des gels et
jaune maintenant alors vous avez pris
moi personnellement ce que j'ai prévu
c'est qu'on va continuer à essayer de
travailler pour la convergence il ya un
moment on a envie on a tous le même
objectif
finalement c'est d'enlever ce
gouvernement qui fait n'importe quoi sur
tous les thèmes tous les thèmes soit la
santé que ce soit la justice
que ce soit la santé tous sur tous les
thèmes il ya un moment on va continuer
et un moment si on a tous le même
objectif qui est d'enlever ce
gouvernement c'est qu'on va tous aller
dans la rue en même temps pour type même
si on a des idées différentes mais en
tout cas l'objectif il est le même donc
on va travailler ensemble pour essayer
de faire ensemble soit tous ensemble
dans la rue
une dernière question gaylord leduc
alors les gilet jaune ça me manquait a
commencé le 17 novembre de l'île 18 très
exactement depuis on a vu beaucoup de
mouvements de protestation que ce soit
contre la réforme des retraites
par exemple est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'avoir été quelque part
précurseur de la colère générale de la
colère sociale dans ce pays précurseur
je vais pas avoir la modestie de dire
que le mouvement était le précurseur le
mouvement a permis d'éveiller les
consciences mais les précurseurs et y en
a qui se bat depuis plus de vingt ans il
n'était pas forcément gilet jaune mais
ils le sont aujourd'hui
il ya plein de gens qui se battaient
pour sa déjà avant qui pointait déjà les
injustices notamment par exemple hier
dans les quartiers aussi dont il ya un
moment nous on n'est pas précurseur
on a juste permis d'éveiller plus de
conscience d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
alors samantha vous l'entendez la
détermination reste la même un même si
effectivement cette mobilisation ne se
passe pas du tout comme prévu alors je
vous dis on connaît très peu de monde
accalmie ici aux lois régulièrement
toutes les cinq minutes des démons des
échauffourées on va dire des
affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et certains groupes d'hommes
vêtus de noir cagoulés et c'est vrai que
l'air est absolument irrespirable de ce
côté de la plaque vraiment cette
manifestation qui avait commencé je vous
rappelle encore une fois dans le calme
est en train de totalement des
génériques totalement
merci beaucoup les l'afa un mot zoé